they were running a mock on shankle road
in belfast
these teenagers petrol bombing a bus
with the driver still on board
northern ireland's first minister
condemned it as attempted murder the
prime minister said he was deeply
concerned by the violence
but this community has given up on
politics and policing
sinister elements are exploiting the
youth and police are under attack
this is not the fault of the front line
police officer
this is a failure of politics and i
believe
there are questions to be asked at the
most senior level in policing
about their ability to lead in a
consistent manner
you know and the only thing that should
govern policing is the rule of law
this tension's been simmering for months
over the brexit protocol
but a decision not to prosecute anyone
for breaches of covert regulations at an
ira
funeral was the tipping point in the
loyalist heartlands they're losing
faith in the peace process stacy graham
a community activist
says nothing ever seems to change this
community has been left behind
we still have high levels of multiple
deprivation we're still living in
poverty
educational under achievement is a
massive issue we have really poor
elemental health
and people just feel really left behind
and disconnected from
mainstream politics dale pankhurst says
he understands the anger
but wants young people to make the
choice he did politics
not violence people are hugely
frustrated they're sexual and tired of
this
but there is a way to change it that's
what that's the message that i must say
if you engage if you empower yourself if
you educate yourself you then in turn
empower and engage your community
and that can make the the real
difference
brexit always posed a risk here
republican violence in the event of a
land
border or loyalist violence in the event
of a sea border
its rock the fragile pace the fact that
society here is still divided by walls
like this one
points to a failure of politics for all
the hope of the good friday agreement
there has been precious little
reconciliation and for as long as
one side is deemed to be winning and the
other losing
there will always be potential for civil
unrest
it's against this backdrop seems
reminiscent of the past
that storm and leaders are under
pressure to demonstrate
a political alternative to street
violence
david blevins sky news in belfast